Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click the link in
the description can get a free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
Do you ever wonder what it might take to make
a fish mad?
Not just like a little irritated or cranky,
but fully leaping-out-of-the-water mad?
Like maybe you’ve done that thing you shouldn’t
be doing where you tap your fingers impatiently
at the glass of an aquarium just to get a
bit of a rise out of its residents.
But they just glide on by like you don’t
even matter.
You’re just a creature on the other side
of the glass, more provoked by a fish than it is by you.
But let us suppose you wake up tomorrow, as
Kafka might say, from uneasy dreams, transformed
in your bed into a monstrous vermin.
Instead of the soft, malleable casing of your
skin, you are now armored with a rigid exoskeleton
made of chitin that you will periodically
shed and regrow.
Your body is now an oval, with four pairs
of legs attached to the middle, thoracic region.
And what does your head look like?
It looks weird.
Almost a bit like a butt, right?
Except that structure at one end of you is
neither head nor butt.
It is, for males, the testes.
And for the females, it is the spermathecae,
a place to store sperm.
This is your actual head.
Much cuter, if you can call a head equipped
with suction cups and a needle cute.
But it is a head, similar to your streamlined
body, that is built for one purpose.
Because you are a fish louse, and you are
about to provoke a fish.
Now despite what the name suggests, you are
not actually a louse.
You aren’t even an insect.
You are one of more than 100 freshwater crustacean
species called Argulus.
While you and your kind are found throughout
the world, some of your relatives likely got
their start long ago in Asia.
They spread around the world as the trade
of carp and goldfish spread not only the fish
but their closest friends as well.
Well, perhaps friends is not the right word.
Parasite.
That one that fits better.
Of course, the name doesn’t matter to you.
Nor does your historical background.
Why track some origin that’s ancient compared
to your lifespan when you probably don’t
even remember your own origins?
The mucus-coated egg laid in a white mass.
Perhaps the weather was warm, and you spent
only a few days amongst the other eggs.
Or maybe it was colder, and you waited weeks.
And then when you hatched, you had many siblings—anywhere
from tens to hundreds of them.
But you’ve gone your separate ways now,
in search of your next meal, and your next home.
Two things that are, for you, the same thing.
And if you find them, you have the chance
to live to the ripe old age of 60 days.
But if your search turns up empty, then survival
becomes impossible.
And that means the situation is urgent, but
you do have a bit of time.
Several days, potentially even up to two weeks,
to swim through the water and find the right fish.
Fortunately, you are not particularly picky.
Sure, you have your preferences.
Who doesn’t?
But at the end of the day, a meal is a meal,
and a fish is a fish.
Sometimes, if you can’t find a fish, you’ll
even make do with a frog.
To get there first, though, you have to swim,
paddling with your legs, and catapulting yourself
from predators using lobes that attach to
your belly to launch yourself away.
But when the opportunity—or fish—presents
itself, the main appendages at work are the
suction cups, or suckers, that you keep stuck
to your target.
And should you need to move, the suckers on
their own are moveable stalks, meaning that
you can direct them independently to scurry
across your meal.
Once you have suctioned yourself appropriately,
it’s time to feed.
Your head comes equipped with a retractable
stylet, that thin tube poking out like a parasitic unicorn’s horn.
Through that stylet will travel whole blood
cells, ready to feed you.
This is a content moment for you.
A fish louse needs only one fish in its whole
lifetime to sustain itself.
And while this may not be the way everyone
would choose to live their life, who can argue
with being well-fed?
The fish, however, takes notice.
As you take up residence on its skin and start
feeding on it, oh boy, does the fish take notice.
And it will try to shake you.
It will scratch its flank up against whatever
objects are around, whether that’s a plant or a stone.
It will leap into the air.
It might even jump onto the concrete of a
garden pond, risking predators and death as
it tries to get you off its back and out of
its skin.
Perhaps it wouldn’t have made such a foolhardy
decision under normal circumstances.
But in the fish’s defense, you have managed
to get just under its skin enough, poking
away with your stylet and proboscis and possibly
even secreting toxins and digestive enzymes
that feed you and irritate the fish.
And no one is quite themselves when they’re
irritated.
But you?
Well, you will just go on, unaware surely
of the damage you have caused, of the response
you have provoked.
Because after all, to you, it wasn’t damage.
It wasn’t meant to provoke.
It was just one creature in search of food,
through whatever means were available to it.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we would like to also say thank you again
to Skillshare for supporting this video.
If you’re feeling like diving headfirst
into some fish now, you should probably know
how to prepare it properly because you are
not actually a fish louse.
And Skillshare can help with that, with courses
like “Simplifying Raw Fish”.
Chef Ken Oringer will take you through a 40-minute
culinary class where he breaks down the basics
of preparing fish at home.
You’ll learn what to look for when buying
fish, essential knife skills, how to select
ingredients, and finally, how to put your
own creative twist on each dish.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they’re always launching new premium
classes, so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
And if you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click the link in the description, you
can get a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium
Membership.
The names you’re seeing on the screen right
now.
They are a bunch of fish louses, no doubt
about that.
They all came on this journey with us because
they love to look at the beautiful world of the micro.
All of these wonderful organisms that we’re
able to capture thanks to the hard work of
our Master of Microscopes James and his really
wonderful advanced equipment.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on instagram or also on tiktok.
And if you want to see more from us, there
is always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.